[Música]
recientemente ha habido mucha
controversia a nivel de américa latina'
sobre el uso del lenguaje inclusivo de
género
mucho se habla sobre este tema pero poco
se habla sobre de qué se trata y cuál es
su finalidad
cuál es su uso y por qué su uso está
siendo impulsado por diferentes sectores
de la sociedad así las cosas entonces
comenzamos con unos datos básicos para
entender de qué estamos hablando el
lenguaje inclusivo de género es avalado
por la organización de las naciones
unidas me remito entonces a la
definición y explicación que da la onu
sobre este tema el lenguaje inclusivo de
género es un modo de expresión oral o
escrita sin discriminación o
especificidad es usado sin importar el
sexo sin importar el género la identidad
de género o el estereotipo de género y
ha sido elaborado y también estudiado
por diferentes grupos
interinstitucionales de esa organización
internacional que busca pues abro
comillas para citar precisamente a este
organismo internacional
contribuir a la igualdad de género en
contextos multilingües
parte de la estrategia también de la
organización de naciones unidas sobre la
paridad de género por eso lo ha
implementado y lo ha puesto en marcha al
interior del organismo haciendo una gran
campaña de comunicación interna para
difundir su uso en los 6 idiomas
oficiales de este organismo
internacional pero más allá de lo que
puedan decir los organismos
internacionales los colectivos y las
minorías que dice entonces la rae que es
la real academia de la lengua española
sobre este cambio o incorporación de
nuevos usos o atributos del lenguaje
español pues la real académia dice que
no se oponen que el sistema se mantiene
rígido en sus límites y establece o los
límites que están establecidos a lo
largo del tiempo pero a la vez están muy
abiertos y flexibles a la creatividad
que despliega dentro de sus pautas es
decir en pocas palabras están abiertos a
los nuevos usos del lenguaje y ajustes
pero dentro de los rígidos límites que
ha mantenido a lo largo de los últimos
años por cuánto tiempo se va a mantener
esa rigidez
el caso es que por ejemplo en países
como argentina este argumento de la real
académia le sirvió precisamente al
gobierno de la ciudad autónoma de buenos
aires para prohibir el uso del lenguaje
inclusivo de género en las instituciones
educativas una medida que por supuesto
provocó múltiples debates en la sociedad
argentina también entre las autoridades
y entre diferentes sectores sociales
educativos y entre las minorías cada vez
que alguien hace evidente el uso del
lenguaje inclusivo de género provoca
todo un tipo de remezón en las
sociedades sino pues veamos cómo quedó
en evidencia cuando el presidente de
brasil jair bolsonaro se burló
precisamente de argentina por el uso del
lenguaje inclusivo de género y por las
dificultades económicas que está
atravesando ese país suramericano pero
bueno más allá de los comentarios que
pueda haber dejado el presidente
brasileño es oportuno mirar en
perspectiva en qué estado se encuentra
el lenguaje inclusivo de género en el
idioma español su uso porque hay quienes
prefieren omitir su uso en el día a día
y porque su uso simplemente pues
garantiza también reconocimiento a
diferentes de la sociedad que por años
han pedido precisamente ser reconocidos
dentro de un idioma dentro de una lengua
como el español que para muchos es
considerado como un lenguaje machista
pero pasa por encima también de los
derechos de los otros que
le dan un uso cotidiano y que sienten
que hacer estas modificaciones pues
simplemente atenta precisamente contra
los usos habituales que puede tener el
idioma pues lo vamos a analizar en el
debate de france 24 espero que haya
quedado que quedado clara la
introducción y le doy la bienvenida
entonces en la ciudad de buenos aires en
argentina al licenciado gerardo arbey
book él es sociólogo y docente es
especialista en educación e integrante
de fórum infancia y también desde la
capital argentina se conecta miguel
business y él es profesor de filosofía y
también es periodista les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y comentarios a través de las
redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde nos
encuentran como france24
s sant y luego que es en mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 en youtube también pueden
ver nuestra señal en streaming y
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que están escuchando nuestro podcast
todos los contenidos del debate ya los
encuentran en diferentes plataformas
estamos en app el podcast en spotify
deezer y en un link
bueno muy bien pues le doy la bienvenida
entonces a gerardo en la ciudad de
buenos aires para comenzar este debate y
comienzo entonces con el punto de
partida básico gerardo gracias por estar
con nosotros y el lenguaje inclusivo de
género es necesario en este momento para
la sociedad para la coyuntura en la que
estamos a nivel social es necesario o no
como lo ve usted
gracias por la invitación a ver no sé si
es necesario y es un posicionamiento
y el problema es que hacemos visible con
el lenguaje yo quería hacer una
aclaración la real academia española
como su nombre crítica es una academia
que depende de la corona española y si
rigen las pautas para el idioma que se
habla en españa no en toda latinoamérica
me parece que importantes siguientes
estamos acostumbrados a nombrar a la
vega de acá de compañera
[Música]
argentina se independizó de
la corona españoles todas sus
dependencias
en 1816
y volviendo a la pregunta no es por lo
menos para mí si es necesario sino que
significa cuál es la importancia
pero no me voy a poner porque estoy en
el colegio y hay una persona claro
adelante primero la seguridad y primero
las reglas para estar en comunidad
adelante gerardo
significa visibilizar
colectivos que históricamente han sido
invisibilizados han sido
consumidos dentro de otros y entonces es
seguro que no es fácil y que significa
un cambio en el idioma
el idioma es
está en constante cambio
si no hablamos el mismo idioma que
hablaba cervantes ni el idioma que
hablaba él sin campeador
entonces el lenguaje está en constante
mutación y lo que significa
tiene que ver con los grados el
colectivo las históricamente
invisibilizados si ponerlo de la palabra
a miguel wiñazki en la ciudad de buenos
aires también para conocer su opinión el
punto de partida es necesario este
lenguaje inclusivo de género
para la sociedad para el momento
coyuntural en que estamos cuál es su
perspectiva miguel adelante bienvenida
bueno muchas gracias es
interesante el lenguaje inclusivo en el
sentido literal de la palabra
interesante se involucra y de acuerdo
con lo que acaba de decir se ha minorías
que estaban fuera de solamente una
representación lingüística y no en buena
medida víctimas de sistemas de exclusión
cuando no de agresión
simplemente por no pertenecer a un canon
que alguien impuso
lo que
desde mi punto de vista es cuestionable
y si toca el filósofo dice la vox dice
que es el uso del lenguaje inclusivo en
este caso
como herramienta demagógica para
encubrir otras exclusiones trató de
explicarme
voy a dar un ejemplo
la convención internacional de los
derechos de las personas con
discapacidad
obliga
con justicia me parece a incluir
en un 4% en todos los organismos
y estatales municipales un 4% personas
con discapacidad no se cumple
no solamente no se cumple sino que
cuando alguien requiere información al
respecto
no es brindada está por los debidos
organismos de las personas con
discapacidad auditiva
o intelectual
están al margen con
esa marginación no se resuelve y éste lo
que dice si se simplemente hablando en
inclusivo
la chiquita se resuelve de
la de estas
personas históricamente
y marginada por
pero consideradas diferentes
por mi dirección y sexual eso se influya
de tal forma que el cuestionamiento que
yo hago es la utilización demagógica del
inclusivo habló en inclusivo la
exclusión material real permanece pero
yo me tranquilizo digamos mi conciencia
y como desierto y me siento exculpado de
esas exclusiones
simplemente porque utilizó la
muy interesante y migueli entonces cómo
evitar ese tipo de exclusiones en el
idioma precisamente se le está dando se
le está tratando de dar este uso a la
letra en algunos casos como como una
forma neutra para para
hablar en el idioma español
entonces cómo evitar estas exclusiones
desde su punto de vista
bueno en primer lugar
tratando de atenuar la demagogia ya mais
y sobre todo y fundamentalmente la
apropiación de un gobierno de la bandera
del lenguaje inclusivo que yo col afirmó
es una causa noble interesante profunda
incluso yo diría necesaria la búsqueda
no se encontró todavía el modo de
regular digamos
y una gramática inclusiva pero es una
búsqueda
diría que es necesaria el problema es la
apropiación
gubernamental demagógica de esa bandera
como si fuera propia de un gobierno segi
no lo es es justamente universal y en
este sentido se producen disputas
digamos en precisamente en corporaciones
políticas para ver quién está favor o
quién está en contra hay que en cierto
sentido liberar el lenguaje de los
intereses corporativos gubernamentales
si interesante ese punto me que le
preguntó entonces a gerardo qué piensa
usted de esta perspectiva de miguel' la
demagogia logra a permear este idioma e
impide ese final para el que fue o para
que está siendo difundido en este
momento que es para que haya una
apropiación por un sector de la sociedad
en específico y no por un colectivo
político no por un gobierno de turno no
por unas autoridades y no logra cumplir
su función su función
y su cometido como lo ve usted
el primero el lenguaje no sólo es para
minorías digo no
las mujeres el feminismo no es una
minoría digo de hecho por lo menos en la
argentina es el 53% de la población
el lenguaje
usar el masculino como genérico también
las está exclusiones no sólo en cuanto
exclusivos primero no es sólo para las
masas y las minorías primera aclaración
segunda aclaración no sé por qué se
mezclan algunos temas tipo primero no sé
por qué el hablar el lenguaje decisivo y
diga en contra de incluir a personas con
discapacidad
por lo menos no no no entiendo la razón
de mezclar estas dos cosas ya sea
lenguaje inclusivo
incluye diversidades que no van en
contra de ninguna otra diversidad
o situación o
entonces que no sé por qué
incluso estas cosas se cuestiones las
cosas buenas porque si hablamos incluye
el lenguaje inclusivo y no estamos
teniendo en cuenta los capacita a las
personas con discapacidad no vendiendo
porque porque para mí no son
contradictorias una cosa con otra ni son
excluyentes
y tercer puesto que quería tocar es lo
que vamos a discutir es el lenguaje
inclusivo
discutir es un gobierno digo yo por lo
menos
invitado
pensar lo que significa el uso del
lenguaje inclusivo que significa la
predicción de nuestro lenguaje inclusivo
en las escuelas que mi tema que
significa la general tal vez usted no ha
entendido bien mi pregunta mi pregunta
es si en algunos casos no está hablando
específicamente el caso argentina estoy
hablando porque esto pasa en todos los
países de américa latina que este
lenguaje inclusivo se ha vuelto una
herramienta de los gobiernos de turno en
algunos casos para una difusión política
precisamente se le pregunta si se está
evitando llegar al verdadero fin de este
lenguaje inclusivo de género que es que
llegue para que sea usado por la
sociedad precisamente porque se está
desviando su verdadero fin usted cree
que hay ese desvío o no o que está
cumpliendo perfectamente con llegar a la
población para que sea usado en el día a
día
a ver yo creo que los cambios no se dan
por decisiones de esas lenguas que no se
dan ni por decisiones de un gobierno ni
por
decisiones de prohibición con gobierno
cuando hay colectivos que toman esto
como bandera como reivindicación tiene
una potencia generadora cuestionadora
del orden que me parece
que
el gobierno te pregunta política porque
estoy preguntando si si se desvía el uso
de la herramienta
entonces le cambio la pregunta para que
entremos en materia porque creo que se
está patinando en el mismo tema le
preguntó entonces si está fallando la
difusión para dar a conocer este tipo de
usos del lenguaje le hablo desde el caso
colombiano donde se usa por algunos
sectores de la sociedad pero muchas
personas evitan usarlo porque
simplemente no lo conocen no entienden
para qué se usa ni qué escenario deben
usar hay un problema de difusión de
estas ideas y ahí sí tienen que entrar
las autoridades hacer unas campañas de
uso no puede quedar solamente en los
colectivos en los sectores sociales
tiene que haber una articulación
sociedad y autoridades no lo creo
totalmente al llevar una articulación
entre los diferentes sectores sociales
gobiernos de siete actos pero digo es
lógico todo cambio trae resistencias o
sea un lenguaje que tiene
300 años de historia 400 en la historia
no sé obviamente que todo cambio va a
estar en resistencia no se cambia de la
noche a la mañana ni por un decreto ni
porque haya alguien que lo viva entonces
que haya resistencia que haya gente que
no estoy de acuerdo forma parte del
proceso sí sí que esto se ha
utilizado por los gobiernos tanto para
para su uso como para su prohibición
me parece que es otro tema digo
con trató entonces de buscar la
respuesta con migración de buenos aires
miguel a usted le parece que hay un
fallo en la difusión de este tipo de
incorporaciones en el lenguaje de su uso
y que precisamente por eso se genera
resistencia precisamente por el
desconocimiento que hay sobre este tema
si la gente entendiera cuál es el uso y
el fin
estaría un poco más
desplegado su uso sin tanta complicación
o como lo vio usted
en primer lugar ciertamente lenguaje
inclusivo es una inclusión de mayoría
por cierto si naturalmente
en todo caso yo lo que creo no sé si no
en un 7 otro modo en segundo lugar el el
problema pero que me parece que es
natural a una mutación enqvist y acá es
que no se comprende bien cuál es la
grama tolo jia profunda pero obviamente
porque es una cuestión que está
desarrollándose en estos momentos
entonces es difícil
enseñar algo que no tiene una estructura
profunda en tercer lugar la real
academia española es descriptiva no es
prescriptiva lo conozco sucede en madrid
describe y describe los usos en
iberoamérica del lenguaje pero no
prescribe ni prohíbe pero es una
institución que podemos asumir como
referencia o no hay otro elemento y es
que el hecho creo que históricamente y
hay muy buenos trabajos entre otros por
ejemplo de sergio ramírez es premio
cervantes al respecto nicaragüense desde
donde se demuestra y es indiscutible que
el lenguaje español ex históricamente
inclusivo
en la argentina el lunfardo como
llamamos aquí
es el permio el castellano español
efectivamente y lo cambió y ahora mismo
en amplísimos sectores populares hay una
los desarrollos verbales orales e
incluso escritos musicales culturales
riquísimos que están cambiando el idioma
ahora volviendo específicamente a la
cuestión del lenguaje inclusivo
yo creo que y respondiendo también
específicamente a la pregunta si hay una
falla en la discusión pero que
precisamente se produce porque muchos
sectores me parece a mí lo perciben como
impositivo
y sectores
antagónicos adictos
y tratarían de imponer su prohibición
es una doble imposición
que
ensucia de alguna manera lo que debe ser
precisamente los procesos de inclusión
discursiva
claro y no es una imposición sino que
como ya lo mencionaba en es parte de la
evolución del idioma me parece que en
esta coyuntura en este momento al idioma
español le está costando un poco
evolucionar al ritmo que está
evolucionando la sociedad a medida que
se abren estas discusiones se abren
estos debates
se garantizan más derechos para
diferentes sectores de las sociedades en
américa latina que históricamente fueron
bastante conservadores y muy permeados
por el tema religioso ya y al idioma le
está costando un poco ir a la par cree
usted o está evolucionando
en conjunto con nosotros
e interesante la pregunta evoluciona en
zig zag en general el lenguaje mismo
tiende a ser conservador a conservar su
[Música]
su regla no o
la gramática de lebrija que es la que
llega a
iberoamérica pero de iberoamérica la
nueva españa y desde allí se expande
justamente una suerte de propósito
teológico político y evangelizador
también se quiso
literalmente imponer y se impuso y se
propagó pero eso no determinó que
la cerrazón absoluta del español se ha
enriquecido
con la evolución social
literalmente en la argentina ahora como
digo hay diversas jergas argots que para
ciertas generaciones son difíciles de
comprender y no son asumidos de pronto
institucionalmente y que sin embargo
también permiten el lenguaje la
inclusión y hay una evolución que va en
zig-zag a veces se retrasa respecto del
cambio social a veces se sintoniza
estaríamos en un punto medio en un punto
medio gerardo continuo con usted para
preguntarle en algo más de la
cotidianidad del día a día de lo que se
ve allá en argentina que en este tema es
uno de los países referentes en la
región por el manejo que le han dado
precisamente también por el debate que
se ha despertado por lo que sucedió con
las autoridades de la ciudad autónoma de
buenos aires en el día a día en el que
usted se encuentra cómo es la percepción
del manejo de este lenguaje inclusivo de
género particularmente el de género que
es el temas
ha generado debate en los últimos en los
últimos meses
a las percepciones que está en debate
que hay sectores que lo aprueban y hay
sectores que lo desaprueba con todo el
proceso social pero queríais sólo es
mucho muy mal señor miguel perdón si por
momento me acerco mucho la cámara pero
escucha muy mal
y si que no es lengua el que está
atrasado sino las instituciones que
sostienen ese lenguaje el que por ahí no
van acorde a los cambios sociales me
parece que el lenguaje no tiene una vida
propia más allá de las instituciones que
lo sostienen entonces por ahí lo que
habría que pensar es cuáles son las
instituciones
que las personas que sostienen un tipo
de lenguaje y cuáles son las personas o
instituciones que sostienen otro tipo de
lenguaje
este es el lenguaje como entendí que
decía
mencionar son arguya je está en
permanente cambio yo creo que poco a
poco se va a ir incorporando esta nueva
modalidad
del lenguaje
porque me parece que los jóvenes y las
jóvenes y los jóvenes
por lo menos en amplios sectores lo
están incorporando así que yo creo que
en ese sentido va a haber un cambio sino
obviamente va a haber
personas que lo van a aceptar mejor
personas que lo van a aceptar con
mayores dificultades
no creo que sea una imposición y no veo
que sea una imposición clara no sólo nos
referimos de la prohibición me refería
específicamente a la prohibición del
gobierno a la ciudad de buenos aires- el
uso del lenguaje inclusivo en las
escuelas
y si hubo una prohibición explícita de
el uso del lenguaje inclusivo a las
escuelas si bien la resolución no dice
específicamente eso pero si la ministra
de fusión y el gobierno
y por eso el debate generado cuando
usted se refiere instituciones solamente
por darle algún ejemplo se refiere usted
por ejemplo a la real academia española
que es una entidad fundada en 1715 jamás
ha tenido una directora mujer en la
actualidad de los 40 académicos que la
integran solamente seis son de sexo
femenino en el último congreso de la
lengua que ocurrió en el 2019 antes de
la pandemia de kobe 19 250 ponencias 32
países participantes y no hubo ningún
tema
debate sobre el lenguaje inclusivo de
género está esta institución un poco
quedada no va al compás justamente
volviendo a tomar el tema de la sintonía
entre sociedad y el lenguaje una cosa
una cosa los miembros de la real
academia son vitalicios eso hacen los
miembros vitalicios siempre tienden a
ser conservadores dílar porque su
inclusión su estabilidad no depende de
cambios sino que por el contrario
depende no son elegidos o elegidas
entonces tiende a ser
a conservar la situación entonces
hay un proceso lógico como vos decís
creo que creo que son más de 40 si no
recordamos eran 44 46
solamente se mujeres eso en el 2022 está
dando significando algo claro
que
la academia
es una institución española que organiza
y para españa
importante punto gerardo regresó con
miguel para preguntarle por la materia
legislativa es momento para que los
gobiernos de américa latina entonces se
intenten legislar sobre este uso de en
algunas algunos lineamientos algunas
luces de cómo empezar a adaptar esto
porque es una realidad es algo que vamos
a empezar a vivir en el uso del día a
día de nuestro idioma del idioma español
y le extiendo un poco más la pregunta a
usted le parece usted ya que el lenguaje
español es un lenguaje bastante
inclusivo pero hay otros que dicen que
es bastante machista
bueno hay un machismo histórico en
iberoamérica en nuestros países
notables
lo cual no ha impedido la inclusión de
dialectos diversos
y de nuevos anima sin revoluciones
verbales de ciertos sectores que han ido
reitero terminando
a lo largo de la historia del lenguaje
español iván ha enriquecido el respecto
del machismo yo diría que
de siempre
acaba de afirmar el machismo social que
se ve institucionalmente también y se
nota en todo en todos los niveles
por ejemplo constituye lo que algunos
analistas denominan la antropología del
ego de leonor una disciplina los
insultos en castellano en argentina son
homofóbicos y antisemitas
yo no pretendo reproducirlos eso no es
verdad y eso es un indicador
profundo digamos de
ese de esa especie de tumor traumático
es el machismo
inveterado raigal en nuestros países
el honor herido te quiere al honor
insultando a la madre de una persona o
calificando sus sexualidad como una
suerte de acción claro y eso ciertamente
es un indicador
nefasto de una de la sociológicamente
hablando
lingüísticamente hablando no de esta
sociedad
de tal manera que
siendo al comienzo de su alocución yo
creo que el momento de dar un debate al
menos parlamentario respecto de todas
estas cuestiones me parece muy general
la utilización demagógica de esto que
piensa usted al respecto momento de dar
un debate de alto nivel a nivel
parlamentario y legislar sobre este uso
me parece bárbaro que el señor viñas te
reconozca el machismo existente
que está implicado en el lenguaje que
usa el masculino como genético la
pregunta si queremos cambiarlo no o sea
si damos esto como natural o intentamos
empezar a hacer algunos cambios
creo yo que el lenguaje inclusivo de
género
apunta justamente a empezar a hacer esos
cambios a que la sociedad sea menos
machista menos discriminatoria y por eso
apoyo el lenguaje inclusivo
creo que está buenísimo que se dé a
nivel parlamentario a su daría pero nos
parece esto lo importante es que la
sociedad empiece a debatirlo y a iu a
pensar no solamente acepta lo que dicen
las instituciones sino lo que justamente
lo que el machismo lo que el lenguaje
machista sexista
implica no sé me parece que ese es el
gran punto este estaría buenísimo me
parece bárbaro cuando desde organismos
oficiales organismos gubernamentales
sea el partido que sea
empiezan a hablar y a influir
con distintos géneros empiezan a hablar
de todos todos todos porque eso hace que
la sociedad entre en este debate y creo
que es un debate que
permea no sólo las las instrucciones
oficiales sino que permea todas las
cosas y me parece un gran
logro de todos aquellos colectivos que
han instalado el más allá de que el
abdomen tal o cual gloria
español no es solamente un debate que se
está dando en lenguas españolas están en
otros idiomas también clase de más de
200 años este este debate
la revolución francesa
que fue hace más de 200 años la primera
fue la declaración universal de los
derechos de la movilidad de ciudadanos
unos y unas mujeres que salieron a decir
que no estaban incluidas en esa
declaración de los derechos de los
medianos en estas cosas no es tampoco si
quiere un debate actual si él ha puesto
hoy en la sociedad porque hubo
diferentes positivos y diferentes
gobiernos y diferentes instituciones que
pusieron entre un debate claro no creo
que en estos momentos nadie lo ponga
como obligatorio digo me parece que es
un posicionamiento si estamos a favor de
empezar a desarmar este machismo o
decimos bueno él
es un
y una raigambre machista y seguimos como
si nada la potencia
y bueno lo que es evidente es que para
poder dar este tipo de debates de alto
nivel por parte de un legislativo en
cualquier país de américa latina se
necesita mucha educación de fondo sobre
el tema conocimiento del lenguaje
conocimiento de esa sociedad y ahí es
donde creo que está el punto principal
de partida de educar primero a la
sociedad sobre este tema antes de
empezar a abrir a expander un poco el
idioma ya abrir los nuevos escenarios
que quedan ya pocos minutos para cerrar
el programa miguel gerardo y quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones de lo que puede
venir en materia de nuestro idioma del
español de este uso del lenguaje
inclusivo de género que va a seguir por
dónde va a comenzar todo esto va a pesar
entonces una educación masiva sobre el
tema o los legisladores se van a meter
de cabeza a hablar de esto sin conocerlo
como puede pasar en muchos casos en
américa latina porque simplemente se
abanderan con los temas o se apasiona
con los temas como ven ustedes que va a
ser la situación generando comienzo y
puntual por favor que me quedan pocos
minutos
yo creo que se va a seguir extendiendo
hasta el debate y creo que cada vez más
la gente va incorporando todos estos
sacamos derechos o sea si uno piensa en
los últimos 50 años ha cambiado
muchísimo a la sociedad en función de
derechos y me parece que el lenguaje
inclusivo nos habla
[Música]
en términos de derechos de derechos de
múltiples colectivos claro que se van a
seguir viendo entonces sí me parece que
la sas como un resentido y cuanto antes
podamos entenderlo profundizarlo y
ponerla en práctica mejor me parece
incluída miguel su conclusión
rápidamente por favor si bueno lo que
viene es la consecución del debate y eso
es positivo con el riego como tú has
dicho recién de que se ha tomado
superficialmente por
de la corporación política de turno aquí
o en cualquier otra parte para
propagandizar sé a sí misma pero el
debate necesario es urgente teniendo en
cuenta también con esto concluido en
argentina las pruebas internacionales
sobre el rendimiento lingüístico de los
alumnos de la gramática han sido pésimas
y eso es un indicador fundamental
también que debemos tener en cuenta es
un punto de partida que nos deja muchas
reflexiones en miguel ese dato que nos
deja para el cierre a gerardo a miguel
en la ciudad de buenos aires- les
agradezco mucho haber estado con
nosotros en este programa de debate de
france 24 gracias por haber puesto en
perspectiva este tema para toda la
audiencia en américa latina' ustedes
muchas gracias por la sintonía pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]